KIRBY DACH.
A CHANCE TO START TH IT IN.
>> Eddie: HE WAS ON THE OTHER
SIDE FAME CAREIT.
HE -- EVERYONE
FEET.
CHECKED BY
THE THE
PUCK.
DANAULT BUYERS AT THE NET  OFF
OF JONES.
I DO NOT
>> Pat: RADDYSH.AND H HE HAS EV.
THE HALLCHANGE HERE..COM
THE KINGS.
HERE IS BROWN.
S DURZI.   DURZI GOT  THAT WERE
THAT'S WHAT WE CALL KARMA  MORE
O
LIZOTTE.
AND THEN HE HAS  AND I SAID, I
GIVE YOU 1000 GUESSES WHYOU HAV
>> Pat: I'M DAN SPENCE.
21 YEARS OLD.
THE KINGS HAVE EXTENDED IT ENOU.
>>ELEVATE IT ON
QUICK.
I THINK THE
WIDE-OPEN NET.
>> Pat: RIGHT NOW, IT IS KANE
LOOKING TO ADD TO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE HA
THURSDAY NIGHT, THE -- WILL BE3
RIGHT THERE. AND.
QUICK.
OUT OF THE CORNER.
DIDN'T COST HIM, THOUGH.
TAKEN BY
>> Eddie: FOR SOME THAT'S GOING
TO BE